you
all right it's been a while less than
five seconds now for a tree check
tournament just like regular chess but
yeah first person to give a third check
and you win
I oppose
some trouble with that mode I'm seeing
hmm let's jump on out rapid development
Knights are dangerous
you're going to push
Oh
I got to take with the clean
that's a bit scary
should check
yeah
that would have been dangerous
take this nice
it's a bit scary
I think I need this night back to defend
they're lining up these kind of
sacrifices
I think I need to get rid of one of
their pieces
here
giving up upon striking at the Queen the
rook to be careful of this
it's one check I think you have to go
here I have a check I missed that
rook takes pawn
like
time
you
holy cow it is tough playing with black
whoo you know what that does not happen
too often where it comes down to just
winning or losing on time Wow
okay this I have probably a broken
record if you've seen these uh three
check variants before this idea with the
bishop coming out and trying for a quick
strike
is uh actually not too good of an idea
to give up a pee
just to give one check that isn't worth
it
trying to neutralize this piece there's
a lag with the queenside development
this is usually a problem piece
I'll keep my structure as is I'm looking
to push this pond okay now I could take
and then go here and pretty much win
yeah I think Bishop here and nearly
anything is going to win
except for Queen here and not just mate
by regularly means
there check all the same got two games
in there Dragonslayer
okay we got clean master it's our first
time playing three check it maybe
okay careful now careful let's go there
and I believe I could already sacrifice
here
and already just take take my night
that's one threatening in late into here
I could just take
hmm
you
something on him I wasted a lot of time
just then
Wow
close to getting my queen sure they
could attract my queen they're only two
checks away
take here that's check number two and I
could get a final check now where's your
king down that's me
who I I was in trouble with Alan
yeah they could have trapped my clean
Bishop g4 when I played Queen h3
all right three games in 37 players are
now on this one
they're already bested by test
from my experience at least
oh what's that about
my test is definitely for for this
variant and there they're already lost
here as two checks and now my queen
simply needs to give a third how you
stopping that how are you doing it gotta
go here
returned here
I should have done that in the last move
that's me
all righty
yeah Queen f3 and the nation
shifted over to the e-file real quick
these games could finish really fast
still 23 minutes left
these early moves you have to be really
careful if I move my deep on they take
this with check I'm just going to
develop
like a win upon can still went upon okay
now I think this might already be
winning for me because he's out of play
he's out of play and I'm a little eyeing
up one check sacrifices over here like I
think it's already gone
clean here
Bishop takes pawn and Knight is worth
the check King here I have this and then
here or some knight move that's it back
to tournament got 16 12 8 8 8
22 left
all right it's probably going to stick
around this point
39 players Crysta
for walking again all right they can
still go out this d5 it's interesting
okay so I could take here though I think
now that's a check that's a second check
and I only need one more check are you
stopping my clean
and I'm just one good move away
right here can't stop clean there
knifing in acts like a primo of it
there's only clean cake spawn to delay
but yeah there is that little sacrifice
there just a breaking through with that
Bishop b4 which is a killer because it's
not just one check your landing let's go
here be careful this stuff
going to take care
with the rook eight
might be an idea
position open just like you would in
regular chess
lead in development
jump in here just to give up upon to
till to land a check right here and it's
Nate
I gave one check I'm ready to take here
and then get on the e-file this is
busted a night move and I could push
their check
analysis again
check all right back to tournament
twenty minutes three four five six seven
games in there
FX's right on my heels he stumbled in
Game one but perfect sense
in 3rd 2016
see we get 41 players now chess X
okay
he knows a little bit of tree check
theory
King f8 or not okay that move yes
Bishop c7 bishop here there's ninety
five and it's already winning yes
here
you know they're playing a strong line
I'm not aware of
hmm
I'm going to take this in try to weather
storm that's one check
wrong my night covers this square very
important
take
let's go here I'm wasting so much time
still wasting time now let's get rid of
this night yeah they're trying to sneak
in I don't have any time I got to get
rid of their pieces that could hurt me
get rid of this night
stuff
that night man
I'm a threat
one two three
oh man with three seconds left I'm
avoiding that altogether
you know if I had a more time I would uh
I'll go back into that variation but
that's who
that is really tough to work out for one
minute game too difficult
no thank you not doing it anymore
okay they have one check in there
and I should be able to defend this now
yes definitely defending this
material ready to smash through
Queen takes her mate and one more check
that's Nate that's a third check okay 32
2016 that was a big win against chess X
I have to try a different variation that
was a that is a line okay Queen Master I
did struggled last time they had their
opportunity for Bishop g4
okay go with this
Shapiro's castle
all right now
push
push I have a strong Center their
bishops not playing so normally you get
this on the black end here here and then
there's some some issue the bishops
functioning on the adjacent diagonals
knife in here I wanted this might just
turn out to be like a regular chess game
I don't see how I'm going to oh now this
is definitely gone that's me all right
36 20 20
once the lights go bishops were gone I
had all all the play I wanted on the
light squares Sicilian one wrong slip in
the early stage and you're in trouble
this little the
let's jump in here Knight takes Knight
with check alright let's go here oh I
also clean here is good picking up the
bishop
Larry I have one check and
[Music]
want to sneak over like sacrifice here
then a night check
try this
Night Moves I take their queen with
check I only need one more check
how do you dance around my night you
gotta you got to go somewhere like that
yeah
all day I don't have all day I'm one
check away
one check away
they're under 20
let's cover this diagonal
rook here if the bishop moves it's game
over
game over they're going to forget
context on
it's check this [ __ ] moves its mate
whose mate there's a great restriction
where is the night they're down that
time yeah it's a tough road ahead and
you give up the Bishop b4
Queen a5 is better queen 85 and you
could even sack the queen and not in
that situation I think Queen a5 is
Bishop d2 play Queen takes bishop
okay 13-inch
change remaining forty forty twenty
eight twenty to twenty
couple with the drawers from the top
page 45 or in their chess X again
okay
maybe I could try something different
like Bishop to b5 oh they're giving me a
check like that that's not right
think they slipped up yeah they they
messed something up there they're in
trouble
I just want to shut this diagonal down
and now open it up let's open it up a
little bit I don't want to open up the G
file
let's go over here on a challenge this
night it's their best piece now I don't
want to take their here and invite their
clean forward okay now there's only two
pieces around
on their bishop
want to go into any imbalance hang on it
up
you know giving
to the bishop oh I get here that's a
second and the third is right around the
corner they resign
all right 12-minute mark 44 28 26 less
than 12
until we get Christopher Walken is in
there with fire three points up from
chess X clean master versus the number
three okay Christopher Walken so this
this is my first time playing as a white
let's try this variation yeah I'm going
to take and play this for a bowl game I
think it's alright let's do this and
take here I'm threatening on clean takes
here I have a sacrifice on this square
let's go here
clean H five it's a very active post
that's scary
I have one check
hmm think here
no boy it's pretty dangerous
pretty dangerous yep
okay
yeah I'm in trouble
and some pretty
trouble oh boy
I am losing
I gave them a lot of activity there
got the Queen I feel like I am still
out of the woods though that's one check
have a check at the second check
and I have a third no matter where they
go
yeah I counted right oh my goodness
I got to rethink that variation Wow
I definitely have to rethink that
variation
I've had success before with that but
that open G file yeah okay
I could go back in for that variation at
least in a 1 minute game but to take the
knight on f6 and open up the G file like
that no way that's a first and last
maybe it isn't a first but yeah
hopefully a last there
here I just do this no biggie had a
similar line against clean master I
think with this I don't know if I want
to castle yeah here's a fishing pole
idea which is very effective they try to
get out of this move with check and now
there's killer ideas if the pond
captures the night and now I have at
least one check in hand
let's get my clean active body lining up
some sacrifices I might launch my jeep
on okay there should be something really
juicy now
really juicy
is covered let's just go here
take my nightmare
just take them
let's go here we'll take this and grab
some material clean here
that's one check
get the bishop
I am diagonal
here push this
ex-con and then I only need one more
check
take him for
they don't have any time yeah down on
time back to tournament land 52 39:35
christopher walken again
okay it's d5 move okay
that huh I'll grab that pond
i lining some
tricks up maybe castle
on f2 I'm going to keep that night
the center phone
yeah let's let's just keep him there
and even start pointing some pieces here
maybe
for
weasel my bishop around inconvenience
the rook now discovered that's a
difficult turn to get out of
hopping in f4 yeah let's open up this
file
this move
okay I still have some play
let's go with this again one check take
so I go here okay that's one check
that night is so dangerous
a slight time edge
careful now I think I could do this how
I made it so dangerous
ma'am
you
oh boy that's a third
a
scowl
one that goes down to the wire man
whoo okay
so much better playing is like team
black is a struggle
problem on d6 now and I'll give that up
so here
I'm going to live the night
look at my bishop over here is defense
this is an interesting line as they're
playing stop that pond from going any
further
I want to neutralize their Bishop I have
one yeah I have one check in there now I
just want to pry open the see file the
main to threat
and stuff up the Queen moves I have this
with check like we could for sure give
one check Queen takes pawn I have this
why don't why do I not just already have
a rook out of the C file I don't need
one more piece so now there's no
defending these last two checks get the
clean over here
over here I guess same story going here
and now there's no defense that's one
check that's a second
excuse me a third
three minutes left one more game for
sure
that's this one let's revisit this line
and it respond properly last time I'm
just going to take the night out and
play here castle you know maybe this is
a line up there just a little bit
uncomfortable with
let's jump up crack up in the center
defend and sift on
squared planning
at the bishop
night and
one check
a killer setting up in May and three one
two three
they missed it
three move combo
got to move the king in the corner after
I played Queen d3
I got 64 one more
two minutes eight seconds 64 42 39:25
two minute mark this tournament flies by
we have Lucas winning
okay so now let's see
at night c6
I'll take with okay forget that
but I just want to complete development
semi-clean around to secure these
squares in case of a night tack this
gave me some material numb
winning some stuff no no I need to take
the other way rook to b8 and then Bishop
here should be a killer
that's one check
Shing moves let's just go here
threatening this stuff
that's going to do it
and that's just me and a third check
more pairing frequency hits
you don't get paired up 50 players on
the nose yep one more a Dragonslayer
all righty
let's play the bishop out
I will gladly give that up and then play
e5
I'll go with this bishop in so many of
the lines
castles right prepared to just sideline
this night
just duck turn it is over okay
it's just the one
take it this night because it frees the
way for my queen
very tempted to just sacrifice here
let's maybe keep that possibility open
Queen c1 queen c1 even facilitate c4
that move
I don't want to oh they were in pre-move
mode
I think they have this advanced then go
for now that's one check and here comes
the final two yeah I got my pick how to
do it many ways and that's a third back
to tournament that's going to do it
fifty players and all I had 68 last one
did not count
sixty-eight 48:42 top three
all right let's go to the pages real
quick two three four and five already
to the 50 of you good games all been a
while
for a three check video three check
stream
you